hey what's up guys my name is Hoshino
and welcome to episode 86 of game
programming so over the last three
episodes we created some sprites some
new sprites right and among them was the
player of course the brand new player
which does like this and and as well as
a bunch of tiles which I have actually
exported out of after-effects yet but we
want to now obviously check out what
these tiles look like in our game but
the thing is I stumbled upon on this
player's sheet here and it's all cool
right it's ready to be an animated
sprite but the thing is our game right
now as I look at all the code the way
that we defined our players here is
really kind of stupid isn't it no that's
okay let me take that back it's not
stupid okay it's absolutely not stupid
it's just not the most efficient way of
doing it it is efficient it's just not
I'm kind of gone back and everything I'm
staying on it what I mean is that this
is this is quite a quite a bit of work
okay right now we have nine sprites that
we want to deal with right sorry twelve
sprites okay three for each direction
now the problem with this is we're going
to need 12 sprite declarations here
that's a bit there has to be an easier
way of doing this right there is okay
and that's what we're going to talk
about today over the next two episodes
this one and the next one we're going to
talk about actually making an animated
sprite class that will be able to handle
this for us because right now if I just
close every other tab we have an open
player you'll see that based on the
direction that we're walking here is
simply changes a sprite to another
sprite okay
and it actually builds the animation by
itself here and that's fine okay that's
a fine way of doing it but we can
obviously automate this process and make
it a bit more Universal rather than
having to type this out but every mod
for example and copy and paste all this
code so that's what we're going to cover
over the next two episodes now for this
episode we're going to talk about
specifically a sprite shape now the
reason we're going talk about sprite
shade is because I want to make
something called a sub sprite shade
essentially so we have this sprite sheet
here right but the thing is for our
front walking animation for example if
we're walking down we want to use only
this
first column here right we don't want to
use everything we just want to use the
first column so how can we divide this
spreadsheet into a smaller spreadsheet
is essentially what I'm saying now there
are several ways we could do this the
way that we kind of do this right now we
launch all these tiles here is a 256
size spreadsheet and we deal with that
the way it is but what I want to do is
actually make a spreadsheet that it's
like a sub spreadsheet of a spreadsheet
so I'm trying to think of a clever name
for it I guess we could just leave it as
a spreadsheet couldn't wait okay that's
fine so we'll make a private stat on
once we'll make that public
we'll make a public static spreadsheet
called play oh okay
and we'll set that equal to new
spreadsheet and it's going to round
erskine is gonna be textures sheets and
player on the score sheet dot PNG
because play on score sheet dog PNG is
our file name here and of course the
size here is not going to be uniform
it's going to be what is this
128 by Oh 896 okay just like that now
because we we haven't defined a
non-square constructor here let's go
ahead do that now I'm going to
essentially copy this constructor paste
it in here except instead of in size I'm
going to change that to int width and in
tight because we're going to set out
that stuff manually now because that
will go well also going to need a public
final int width and height oops
so two constants here four over here
width is going to equal size and height
is going to equal size because of course
that is actually correct and for our new
constructor though let's make sure that
we are first of all set based off
particle path also make sure that we
actually load our sheet from the path
let's set size equal to negative one
since it's not square so in other words
if we get negative one we can say that
we've got something wrong here let's set
width equal to width
so we'll set the constant width over
here equal to this width and we all set
height equal to our height parameter
okay just like that
also don't forget to set pixels equal to
new int width times height
okay cool now we've got a sprite sheet
that is not a square and we can load
that what I want to do now is actually
make a third a third constructor okay so
we've got two out here I'm gonna make a
third one probably put it up here and
it's actually going to take a sprite
sheet as a parameter well what's going
on here I'm gonna call a shape that's
right it's gonna take a sprite sheet as
a parameter and what is going to do is
also specify let's uh let's do it this
way
int X int Y int width and in ties okay
I'm thinking that's probably a good way
of doing it yeah okay so what we'll need
to do here is actually specify this is
like a sub shade here we actually have
to specify a shade and then what what
section of the shade we want to crop out
now because this might be a bit
difficult we'll also make a sprite size
variable here so I'll call it sprite
sighs okay cool so what we want to do
now is actually get the X&Y here let me
just think how I want to do this so we
want to make a new obviously pixels is
now on its own instance here and that's
fine so we want to make sure that well
since since um let's make sure that we
actually redefine Axia because let's
change this to x times oh sorry x times
sprite size because of course we'll be
specifying it that way we'll need to
change the old days so I'll make YY I'll
make W for width and H 5 and this is
going to be the width is
we don't need to do that do we hey I'm
just thinking no we do
okay so width times sprite size and
height kind of sprite size as well as Y
times right size okay so now we've got
all those variables we need a full loop
that will actually extract the required
pixels here so for int I equals 0 I is
less than I'll sorry the con is that in
y equals 0 Y is less than for now we'll
just deal with them will change this
will changes radically in a minute I
just want to get the basic for loop down
and we'll make it
nested both will make X as well here
whoops so X is less than with X plus
plus okay cool so now we've got this
sorted out this isn't my merkel let's
call this man this is annoying
I'll just call this y0 I guess man Sarah
because I'm our original names are taken
by the parameters here okay cool
so this will essentially just extract
the width and height we want now we
could yeah okay so what we need to do
now is actually make a Y variable here
so we are really running out of space
here Y P Y position right and that's
just gonna be essentially YY okay simple
as that
and we'll do the same for X so X
position is going to be X X but make
sure that it's not just YY it's actually
YY plus y0 because that's why one off to
vertically and this is xx plus x0 all
right so that's some that's that's
looking pretty good right now
so now what we want to do is take our
current pixels right make sure that we
do actually nestle eyes it so pixels is
going to equal new int essentially it's
going to be let's see here so if the
width is no it should just be with
width times height times age okay
because that of course is the width and
height of our are pixels here that's not
offset that this is the offset here okay
that is the actual absolute width and
height if not an x1 and y1 conic
coordinate so pixels pixels XP plus YP
times our actual width here which is
just W is going to oh no sorry my bad
make sure that you use the original B
for loop things here and what this is
going to do it either this should be
sorry this should be within um hi
so basically what I've got going on here
in case you guys aren't really following
and following along here width and
height is not going to be specified in
pencil precision here it's gonna be
specified in pretty much the brightest
pride precision so if if we want to take
the let's just say we want to take be
two sprites across we would put the
number two here again that will take the
two sprites on the x-axis now this w is
in pixel precision because we're
multiplying it by the size of our
sprites so because we want to extract
the pixels we need to make sure that we
are using our arm or all of our pixel
precision stuff in our for loops so
pixels x 0 + y 0 times width is going to
actually equal shape dot pixels at now
this time X P plus YP right times our
sheets width which is sheet dot width
okay
simple as that so now we've got that
going on that's pretty much it right
what we want to do here is also specify
the width to be W the height to be H and
the size to be negative 1 since it's not
going to be square well see it could be
square but we could say over here just
in case just in case we did want to use
size somehow so we could say something
like if um if with actually equals
height right then a size equals width
else sighs there goes another one yeah
essentially in with equals if if with
does equal type will set will set size
equal to width otherwise we'll just set
size equal to negative one which is what
we do in case one are a square okay
because that's how we roll
okay so what this method should now do
right is essentially extract a
particular sheet from a spreadsheet so
the way that work the usage of this is
going to be public static spreadsheet
player down okay and this is actually
going to be a sheet of his down
animation which is going to be at this
current point these three sprites okay
so player underscore down equals new
spreadsheet and we're actually going to
use player as a parameter X and y are
going to be 0 width is going to be one
and height is going to be three again
and the sprite size of course is 32 okay
that those are the parameters that we
need now how do we know if this worked
or not
that is um one of the question arrows
here we could um test it using an
elaborate method here or we could just
simply draw this pixel array now we do
have a way to draw a pixel array I
believe if we go if we go into our
screen class real quick this is just for
demonstration purposes so we have we
have renders we have render sprite don't
we what I want to do quickly just for
the purpose of testing this this is
really good for debugging as well is
render sheet okay and this will just
render a sprite sheet instead of a
sprite now you guys might be like why on
earth are you doing this and it does
have is it does have its usages but it's
awesome for debugging okay so it doesn't
get hype method but there is a width
sorry height mom will also go sheet dot
width here and
of course we'll go sheet pixels which is
a nice method here and sheet dot with
okay
just like that a natural grandeur a
sheet so if we go now into our game
class and over here in our render what
we can type now is simply a screen dot
render sheet let's just pop it at like
40 40 and just to test this out let's
first make sure that we do a sheet that
does work so for example our um just our
normal player yeah fix will set to false
okay so we don't we want it to fly it
around so let's launch this and what we
should see here is as you can see our
entire player sheet now let's substitute
this and type in a sprite sheet player
underscore down okay and if we launch
this what we should see is as you can
see just be just that section of those
of the sprite sheet and now what we
should be able to do next episode is
play around with this in terms of um
actually making an animated and making a
class that can handle animation by
itself no matter what sprite shape we
faded so um I hope you really hope you
guys enjoyed this episode of game
programming if you did please hit the
like button now in terms of likes
if we hit 300 likes I'm gonna release
two episodes tomorrow you know same deal
if I if we hit 200 likes I am going to
release one episode tomorrow otherwise
I'll probably take a little break to be
honest because um I'm actually kind of
thankful women I think we only reach
like 250 likes for yesterday's episode
which is um um I I pretty much breathe a
sigh of relief there because it's I got
home today at 8 o'clock it's a
twenty-one right now I literally just
got home at 8 o'clock from university of
debt today and I have like three
assignments due next week as well as one
to like tomorrow so I don't know I'm
really busy but the thing is if you guys
like these videos like that just
motivates me to manage my time a lot
better so it's not like I don't have
time it's just that I like to
procrastinate a lot but um yeah so
thanks for all the support guys that
really does help me out and other than
that guys I'll say I'm pretty sure this
episode will drift to underlie so I'll
see you guys tomorrow
guys
you